what's racing fans are gearing up for
next month's Kentucky Derby but on 60
minutes this Sunday we'll show you an
upcoming horse race you may not know
about the Maryland Hunt Cup is a
grueling four mile course known as the
most demanding event in timber racing
America's version of steeplechase we're
riding with jockey Erik Perez it's one
of the many races in the fall in spring
when timber jockeys roamed the rolling
hills of Virginia Maryland and
Pennsylvania in the run-up to the
Maryland hunt Cup the sport originated
in Ireland 250 years ago when horseman
raced through the countryside jumping
hedges along the way the timber fence
issues in this country are more
intimidating some are on a slant some
overwater for horse and jockey each jump
is tricky you're approaching a five foot
fence
what's in your head well number one you
hope you've been living right patty
Nelson is a legendary jockey and trainer
from a family that's been riding and
racing since 1875 he won his first major
race when he was 15 and won the Maryland
Hunt Cup three times can you tell us
what it's like to feel the exhilaration
there's just some magic about the power
of that animal underneath of you and
then when you ask him for everything
he's got the last quarter of a mile or
something like that it's great you can
see a full report on timber racing on 60
minutes this Sunday night at 7 six
central right here on CBS I just really
are mad boy I just want to share what we
were saying gales going charlie is that
you on the horse